What is a behavioral report?
There are several types
of behavioral reports.
They show the performance of our
content, the action visitors took.
It visualizes the path users
travel from one page to another or
from one event to the next.
In apps it will be
from screen to screen.
These reports can help you discover what
potential content keeps user engaged.
It also can help you
identify potential issues.
Okay, let's see how to use it.
Here, we just click in
the behavioral pane on Overview, and
we'll get the first report.
The Overview gives you
a high level summary
of what users interact with your site or
app.
For instance,
here you can see the page views,
the unique, time on page,
bounce rate, and many more.
If you want to see the full report, just
go to the bottom and click, and you'll
get all the detailed scenarios and
data of what happened with your site.
Another very useful report
is the behavioral flow.
If you clicked on it,
you'll what are the paths that users
took when they traveled your site?
This report could help you
identify potential problems or
where are the pages that
the users are most engaged with